today I'm wearing shorts why because
this California heat wave has never made
my balls this sweaty before the heat yes
that is describing my scrotum at this
moment this movie's a buddy cop comedy
action flick instead of two male leads
this time though they got two female
leads one is a very very very funny lady
Melissa McCarthy she's really good at
playing fat people I'm not just people
mean-spirited people she's just really
good at having all these different types
of qualities that can usually be kind of
annoying on screen but she manages to
make it really [ __ ] funny to watch I
don't you got some hate the other day
for you know being overweight well you
don't think I can go [ __ ] himself
because let's remember the more cushion
for the pushin and then you got Sandra
Bullock believe it or not she's like 59
or something like 40 I I forgot a real
age whatever but doesn't matter she
looks like 25 years younger than what
she is she is still really hot I will
still love to hold her hand one day I
mean look at her she's super talented
Oscar winner but she also is in this
movie has a great sense of humor at all
these buddy cop movies you got the one
character who's more of the straight
hardcore at the desk type of person and
then he got the other one who's more of
like I'm on the streets and I'm a little
bit obnoxious and the to play off each
other very well in this movie but what's
really interesting about Sandra Bullock
is yes she's more of a straight
character type of [ __ ] man I really want
to have sex with Sandra Bullock but she
still manages to be really funny I'm
gonna give some other movies with a
straight character it's not so funny but
this one yes very funny very bangable
the directing bypoll [ __ ] ha I bet no one
at school ever made fun of him like that
before if I use that word and I offended
some of you guys just so you know I'm
not homophobic I say I'd suck a lot of
people's dicks on this show there we go
to clear the air anyway pull fate or [ __ ]
whatever he is doing a really good job
you did bridesmaids now he's doing this
movie he managed to sort of bring that
old school 1970s cop sort of vibe to it
at the same
I mean managed to establish a great tone
where you could just have really great
mean-spirited comedic elements but yet
still kind of a lifting at the same time
I'm not gonna lie by the end of this
movie I was cheering up a little bit
just a little bit but don't say that
doesn't make me a man because I'm still
very beautiful night I abandon my child
you can tell this guy lets his actors do
a lot of improv so I think the editing
and this is great just their back and
forth is so much fun to watch the
chemistry between sandra bullock and
melissa mccarthy makes this movie worthy
of having a sequel plus there's a lot of
great cameos in it I don't want to ruin
a there for you but I'll give you some
teasers as Marlon Wayans you know the
guy who made the incredibly awesome
white chicks my one complaint about this
movie is this it doesn't really have
that much action and when there is
action I thought it could have been a
little bit more fun could it be a little
more inventive could have been a little
bit more community could have just done
something a little bit more with the
action after all it's a buddy cop movie
so you expect a little bit more bang
bang you know what I mean but you know
these guys aren't Shane Black it's Paul
fake this movie itself on its own merits
is just a hilariously good time let me
get straight to the point here all in
all I gotta say that he got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
show why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me what is
your favorite Sandra Bullock or melissa
mccarthy movie and if you want to see a
more in-depth review of the heat go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see that i do with my buddy
Jerry or we give you reasons to see and
not to see the heat as you want to
follow me on twitter you can click the
link right here and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time
one of my reviews is out go ahead and
subscribe to my channel by clicking on
the link right here by the tennis yes
where the real heat is at